hey dr. Peterson I'm curious about the
connection between aesthetic beauty and
religious experience ank you painted it
once or twice over the courses lecture
is it possible for something that's
incredibly beautiful to evoke a
religious or mystical experience or
something in the same ballpark I think
that's what they're for yes I chance no
I mean if you look at the structure of
like like a Renaissance Cathedral you
know II was just gonna write right my my
tag on till I apologize you mean to
trump my tag on to that question the
next part was um is that why we have
cathedrals built like a spectacular
buildings as opposed yeah well its
Oxford right well it's if you're going
to house the ultimate ideal you build
something beautiful right to to
represent its dwelling place and it
should be beautiful and this is
something that people do not take
seriously and this is especially
something we don't take seriously in
Canada I mean one of you think about you
think about all the hundreds of millions
of dollars that were invested into
beauty in Europe means spectacular
excessive investment in beauty that's
paid back god only knows how many
multiples of times people make
pilgrimages to Europe constantly because
it's so beautiful that it just staggers
you Beauty is so valuable and we're so
afraid of it and I think we're afraid of
it because it does it's a pathway it's
not the only pathway to the divine I
mean there's lot there's pathways to the
divine love was one of them I suppose
but beauty especially for people who
have an affinity for beauty it's it's
like music it's one of those things that
you can't argue against right you can't
even understand it just hits you and and
it does it shows you well it shows you
the ideal that's one way of thinking
about it but it also shows you I think
it's like a vision of the potential
future it's something like that as well
that if we just got our act together and
and beautified things that that's the
place that we can inhabit and that would
in noble us and that's why this
Jerusalem the heavenly City is paved
with gemstones you know their
crystalline the emit light and yeah it's
the proper dwelling place for an
enlightened consciousness
beauty is the proper dwelling place for
an enlightened consciousness and we we
ignore it at our spiritual and economic
peril
it's our like it's obvious that beauty
there's almost nothing more valuable
than beauty economically practically
right so yeah why that is I mean I don't
it's very who knows you know what I mean
why we we experience gemstones for
example as beautiful it's very
mysterious but they're deep reasons for
it so
[Applause]